all right hi everyone hi my name is Karl
targets and I am a R&D scientist here
with thermo Fisher Scientific working
within cell biology and today I'm going
to talk a little bit about embryonic
stem cell
that's embryonic stem cell FBS that's
been qualified which is a specialty
serum product and you know before I get
really into that I just wanted to
encourage everyone you know if you're
checking this talk out to check out some
of the other content we have going on
all throughout this time period all day
and there's some really good and
beneficial information out there so I
hope that if you're exploring this
you'll also look into some of the other
great things that we have on deck as
well
so to first talk a little bit about
embryonic stem cell culture in general
so this field is involved evolved quite
a bit since the very beginning and we're
at the point now especially within human
stem cells where most of the culture
systems are actually fully defined
medias however traditionally mouse
embryonic stem cells were actually
cultured using fetal bovine serum or FBS
and this was also true in some cases
with human cells because of this fact
and because FBS is not a fully defined
additive it really knits has
necessitates very stringent testing and
the main thing that that that needs to
be ensured when that testing is done is
that it's able to support
undifferentiated growth of embryonic
stem cells and the image on their right
you can see there shows what you would
be looking for if you did have some
mouse embryonic stem cells that were
grown in media containing qualified FBS
and I'll get into the details of that
morphology and what they should look
like a little more but before I do that
I just wanted to highlight some of the
different options and methods that are
currently used in order to qualify FBS
as embryonic stem cell grade one of
those options is colony forming assays
another is immunostaining I mean there's
also options that allow you to quantify
the pluripotency gene expression either
through flow cytometry or qPCR so we've
considered all these options when we
designed the assay for our FBS and ended
up settling on a version of a
colony-forming assay for a few different
reasons that I'll get into on the next
slide so this will allow this slide
gives you a better idea of exactly what
I'm talking about when I talk about our
colony forming assay and so it begins
with thawing cells specifically the PR
x1 29 x1 nearing embryonic stem cell
line and it looks at both plating
efficiency and pluripotency maintenance
and so after these cells they thought
they're allowed to grow for a few days
in in media containing on your FBS that
we're testing and then we also have a
positive and negative control so the
negative control being a condition that
does not have LIF and the positive being
one that does contain lift so LIF is
leukemic inhibitory factor and that is
an important additive that allows the
stem cells to grow the way that we would
expect them to and again I'll mention
that again later but as you can see in
the left panel
after we allow them the cells to grow we
perform alkaline phosphatase staining
and then image those wells and then
count them so as you can see and the
difference between the lift and no lifts
conditions are quite significant what we
look for when we're looking for ap
positive or alkaline positive alkaline
phosphatase positive colonies is a very
bright red stain without ink fuzziness
or ill-defined borders so these are very
tightly packed bright colonies as you
can see in the upper image of the left
quadrant by the same token the condition
without lift
very few of these and is much lighter in
color more fuzzy and spread out and so
after we performed that count we do a
stain with methylene blue which is a
general cellular marker and this allows
us to calculate the total number of
colonies within each well once we have
that number actually once we image and
count those colonies were able to then
divide the total number of alkaline
phosphatase positive colonies by the
total number of colonies which gives us
a percentage of alkaline phosphatase
positive colonies or in other words a
percentage of pluripotent colonies
within the well this really is a useful
tool because it allows us to as I said
quantify the number of pluripotent
colonies which is again the most
important measure that you can have we
as I mentioned we looked at other
options for this assay but without a
full genome-wide transcriptome analysis
you wouldn't be able to get the same
thing you're getting with just looking
at the number of positive ap colonies as
a percentage so looking at the graph on
the right we also looked at the
consistency of this assay by looking at
three different users performing that
assay and how their results compared as
you can see all three of the users
resulted in very similar numbers of AP
positive and colonies as a percentage
and so this gives us a high level of
confidence in our fps is uh excuse me in
our assays ability to be consistent and
without high amount of variability so I
mentioned the cell line that we're using
for this assay and you can see the full
name of it there in the first bullet
point but I'll refer to it as PR X 129 X
1 and this is a murine embryonic stem
sign stem cell line that we get from
prime regenexx and so after this cell
line was grown in
Media containing our FBS I wanted to
make sure that it was behaving the way
that you would expect and it wasn't
having any issues so the first thing we
wanted to look at was the karyotype of
our cell line it's important that for
stem cells especially that this is a
normal karyotype and so that's what you
see in the bottom left hand corner is
the karyotype analysis from a
traditional g banding method and you can
see that is come came back normal which
again is important a lot of different
stem cell lines whether it be human or
mouse tend to acquire Theriault typic
abnormalities when they're grown and so
it's important to monitor that and make
sure that there are no issues there
second thing we looked at was lift
responsiveness I mentioned LIF earlier
that's leukemic inhibitory factor which
is an important addition to media for
mouse embryonic stem cells and allows
them to maintain pluripotency so if a
mouse embryonic stem cell line is LIF
responsive it means that with lift in
the media it's able to maintain
pluripotency and you can see in the
graph that the positive lift condition
does have a high percentage of
pluripotency
as calculated by the alkaline
phosphatase positive colonies divided by
the total number of colonies and by the
same token the negative the LIF negative
condition has very few positive play bug
colonies the other things that we took
elect look at were the expression of
pluripotency markers by both
immunostaining and dyes and also just
morphology so in the quadrant of images
on the right hand side of this slide the
upper left is just a phase contrast
image at 5x magnification and these
cells really exhibit the hallmark traits
of pluripotent stem cells including a
sharp refractive edge
tightly packed colonies with the cells
grown growing very close together and
high nucleus to cytoplasm ratio
on to the right of that is the live AP
stain which is a dye that transiently
diffuses out of the cell over time and
allows for use of these cells in later
applications it's not a terminal end
point assay and as we mentioned earlier
alkaline phosphatase is a marker of stem
cells the bottom two panels show acht
four and sox2 immunostaining which both
are important transcription factors that
are pluripotency markers you can see
high levels of expression for both of
those in those two images I also wanted
to highlight the fact that ESL qualified
FBS is not only useful within your
traditional standard culture practices
it's also able to be used in more
sensitive assets such as reprogramming
so this slide shows you the results of a
reprogramming experiment and that we
performed with both human and mouse
fibroblasts using site attune 2.0
reprogramming kit and what that is
that's our Sendai virus based
reprogramming kit and so you can see a
workflow there across the top at day 0
we transduced the fiberglass for both
the human and mouse cells using site
attune 2.0 and then at day 7 these were
replated onto a feeder layer of cells
and the media at that point was changed
from the fibroblast medium which is DMM
with 10%
yes qualified FBS to an ESC medium which
is slightly different whether it's human
or Mouse for the human we have DMM with
15% ES qualified FBS and fgf whereas for
the mouse we have the same basic
composition DMM with 15% yes qualified
FBS with an additional M Mouse LIF
instead of fgf and after that whole
process you can see the colonies that
were generated these two wells are
showing an alkaline phosphatase stain
again to identify the pluripotent
colonies and you can see that a
significant number of colonies were
generated for both human and mouse cells
and these were you know pluripotent
colonies that were able to be picked and
turned into usable cell lines later on
down the road so again the point of the
slide being that this FBS is able to be
used in more sensitive assays and
processes such as reprogramming not just
your standard routine culture so the
next thing we wanted to take a look at
was how our FBS stacked up against the
competition so we did this by taking our
same cell line that we use for our
qualification assay flying it and then
passages that into five different
media's that were the same except for
the FBS that was it was supplemented
with and that included FBS es qualified
FBS from thermo Fisher Scientific as
well as four competitors and then now
that the cells had been separated into
the media's with different FBS they were
grown for three passages and finally
analyzed for population doublings
morphology and pluripotency markers so
I'll start by having the population
doublings and over the course of the
three passages we saw that all five
conditions all five different FBS is
from the four different companies and
thermo Fisher showed a similar very
excuse me similar
doubling times which was between about
six and a half and eight hours as far as
morphology goes the cells that were
cultured in embryonic stem cell
qualified FBS from thermo Fisher
actually had a relatively higher degree
of homogeneous colonies with that
classic morphology of undifferentiated
stem cells that I mentioned earlier
which has that tight closed tight border
that's very refractive cells that are
going to grow very close together and a
high nucleus cytoplasm ratio and we saw
that more consistently in the thermo
Fisher
and the final measure that we looked at
for the comparison of the different F
FBS qualifier embryonic stem cell
qualified FBS lots from different
companies was pluripotency marker
expression we did this by using flow
cytometry so on the far left of the
screen can fixme the far left unstained
control that's in black you can see we
use that to set our gate for our SSE a1
marker which is what we used in order to
evaluate the pluripotency marker
expression and this is a classic
positive pluripotency marker for mouse
embryonic stem cells we also had a
positive control which is what we ran
initially right after the right before
the cells were split into their
different media and FBS conditions and
as you can see that is largely positive
for SSE a1 when you look at the
different conditions that we tested you
can actually see that Thermo Fisher
Scientific FBS really recapitulated the
positive control very closely in other
words over the three passages the
percentage of positive SSE a1 positive
cells didn't change very much at all
stayed very consistent whereas for all
four of the competitor FBS is that
number dropped a little bit so now that
you've kind of seen the design of the
assay which allows you to qualify that
allows us to qualify embryonic stem cell
FBS and how well it does against you
know other companies FBS as well I just
wanted to highlight the options that are
available for our FBS in terms of both
the origin of the FBS and the size of
the container so we have 100 ml 500 mil
and then also the one-shot format which
I'll talk a little bit more about as far
as origin goes you can get the FBS from
usda-approved regions as well as US
origin and New Zealand origin so there's
a lot of options in terms of not only
the origin but also the size you might
need depending on how much FBS you're
going through in your workflows in your
lab so to expand a little bit more on
the one-shot ESL FBS so this is
available in the ESL qualified version
and the benefit here is that it's
aliquot free so you're not forcing your
FBS to go through an extra freeze-thaw
cycle which is you know very beneficial
because if you're not using a whole 500
mil bottle and you need to aliquot it
you know you're you're putting you know
and your FBS through an extra free sauce
like which can be problematic if you're
using a ton this may not be beneficial
for you but if you're using small
amounts at one time then this can be
very helpful um this has also been
improved on from the first generation by
making a wider mouth and so that all
pipette tips can fit in and it also fits
nicely in a 30 millimeter test tube rack
I also want to mention that there are
free samples available on the thermo
Fisher Scientific website as you can see
from the screen cap there's just a
little button there and it's just a few
lines to fill out before you're able to
obtain a free sample so you know if
that's something looking at testing and
this would be a great opportunity to go
check that out and get what you need so
in summary the advanced assay that we
used to qualify our es qualified FBS was
designed to sustain
undifferentiated embryonic stem cells
while maintaining karyotype integrity
Lifford
responsiveness as well as pluripotency
markers and it has proven applications
in IPC generation and PSC culture
including reprogramming pluripotency
marker maintenance as well as
pluripotent stem cell morphology
maintenance
we also saw that adds superior
performance over competing products with
regard to morphology and especially
maintenance of pluripotency and there is
a newly designed aliquot free one-shot
version available now and able to get
free samples of that on our website so
thank you